las corrientes de agua siguen
recorriendo con fuerza El Salvador
Es una de las evidencias del paso de la
tormenta tropical Julia por el país
centroamericano allí dejó al menos una
escena de fallecidos entre ellos cinco
soldados que se resguardaban de la
tormenta
Julia también azotó con fuerza Nicaragua
con palas y escobas los habitantes de
Managua limpian los estragos que dejaron
las lluvias un millón de personas se
quedaron sin luz y más de 13.000
personas tuvieron que evacuar los
residentes relatan Cómo vivieron el
pasto del fenómeno meteorológico todo el
día con viento lloviendo y el río
metiéndose más para acá esa pobre gente
la tuvieron que evacuar y pasamos así
este pasó lloviendo lloviendo con
bastante viento y el ruido creciendo se
nos llevó el pozo del agua es la esta
Cómo se llama la bomba hasta hoy la
llamo pero estamos sin agua Guatemala
declaró el estado de calamidad por 30
días y canceló clases ante el peligro de
las lluvias persistentes mi las personas
han sido trasladadas albergues
provisionales
que se están ocasionando por Julia en
toda Centroamérica y especialmente en
Guatemala son copiosos esperamos lluvias
muy fuertes y ya tenemos prácticamente
inundaciones tenemos personas soterradas
El remanente de lluvia que nos quedará
será de aproximadamente 48 72 horas
después con probabilidad de inundaciones
en la mayoría de las cuencas de los ríos
del país cuya tierra el domingo en la
costa caribeña de Nicaragua antes de
cruzar el océano Pacífico y a pesar de
que se degradó el Centro Nacional de
Huracanes de Estados Unidos advirtió
sobre condiciones de oleaje peligroso
que amenazan la vida sobre todo en las
costas del Salvador y Guatemala
además señaló que las lluvias aún
podrían causar inundaciones repentinas